Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode Live
on the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Litmus, a chaos engineering project for Kubernetes.
Litmus has a two point x release coming
up, and we're gonna see some of the
new features available from Kartik, the maintainer of
the project.
Before we dive into that, there's just a
little bit of housekeeping.
First, you've not subscribed to the YouTube channel,
now would be the best time to do
it. Click that subscribe button,
and feel free to tick that bell. That
just means that you will get notifications for
all new episodes of Rawkode Live,
and
I will do my best to make sure
we cover as many cloud native technologies as
possible to guide you and help you on
your journey into this vast, vast ecosystem.
If you wanna come and chat with other
cloud native enthusiasts about Kubernetes, cloud native, and
anything in between, we also have a Discord
server available at Rawkode.chat.
Come in there, say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you.
I also wanna thank all of the people
that have now become members of the Rawkode
Academy on YouTube. You can do so for
as little as $1.
This just supports the channel. There's also other
tiers, which will get you interactive courses, which
launched this week,
and a very special tier just for the
corporations out there that also wanna say thank
you. So check that out.
I very much appreciate it. Now we're gonna
move on
to introducing Kartik, a maintainer of the Litmus
project. Hey there, Kartik. Welcome back.
Hi, everyone. It's great to be back
on Rawkode.
I think was an awesome experience the first
time
that we talked about SKAOS engineering and
the evolution of cloud native SKAOS engineering,
and I'm really happy to be back here.
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
Giving me this opportunity to talk to the
upcoming 2.co.
Yeah. It's it's my pleasure. I had a
an absolute blast learning about Litmus the first
time, and I I'm really excited to see
what new things you have coming from the
project.
But just before we dive into for anyone
who didn't meet you the first time, Ryan,
can you just give us a quick introduction
to yourself, who you are, and what you
do?
Sure.
Thank and
this is
wonderful again to be back here. And, Kartik,
one of the maintainers of the Litmus Chaos
project. It is a CNCF
sandbox project.
And Litmus is
cloud native chaos engineering
platform,
I would say.
And it helps you to
practice chaos engineering on Kubernetes
as well as
on pre Kubernetes infrastructure
that you would have. That's how how we're
calling it today. These two instances,
basically, Azure VMs or your
VMware VMs in your data center.
You can go ahead and practice clear engineering.
Clear engineering is not just about injecting faults.
It's a it's a lot about hypothesis,
what you expect
in the system when you're engineering a fault,
and being able to derive meaning out of
an experiment, learn new behavior about your systems,
and not recklessly taking it. So we talked
in the last episode on Rawkode about what
is KS is where it is and what
is not.
We will develop that a little bit today,
and I'm very happy to introduce the newer
version of the Litmus platform.
We are trying for the launch of the
next release 2.0
latest
in August,
and this
would be some kind of technical preview of
some of the features there.
Thank you to a lot of the members
in the community who have been actively testing
it and providing
your feedback on the beta that we have
out there.
So, yeah, looking forward to interacting with you
all.
Awesome. What's that? Just to just to clarify
there, this is a preview of Litmus to
it's not out quite yet, but it's gonna
get people a good taster of all the
awesome new things that are coming down the
pipe.
Alright.
Awesome.
Okay. So
do you wanna talk about some of these
new features first or would you rather just
show us an action? What what would you
prefer, Classic?
Yeah. I'll probably give you a
couple of
pointers.
Think
as we go along doing the demo and
talk about the history of how the feature
came about,
the bot requests in the community actually
give rise to that feature and
Everything is a resource in Kubernetes, and you
have controllers to reconcile those resources.
And people are used to that model
or that particular
paradigm of running their operations on Kubernetes.
And
all your policies,
all your resource
details,
the applications and and its life cycle management,
infrastructure, everything is decorative,
managed, and get,
etcetera. So when we wanted to do chaos
in a similar way, we didn't have the
solution
right at that point of time, and we're
talking about
sometime late two thousand seventeen
to mid twenty nineteen period.
So we came up with Litmus and the
intent of Litmus Cortex was
to provide
chaos experiments
or simple fault injections,
which you could define in a YARL and
which could be carried out by Kubernetes
or or a controller in other words.
And after we achieved that,
we got to know that there's much more
to chaos engineering
than just being able to define a fault.
You must be able to define the
blast radius,
for your
experiment.
What is it that you want to impact?
What is it that you do not want
to touch? How restricted should your experiment be?
And then
we came about the necessity for
automating these experiments in a good way or
schedule them.
Sometimes you want chaos run-in
random
fashion.
Sometimes you want it to run-in
a strictly scheduled
or sequential way.
So it sort of
and one of the things we learned as
we went along
is
why chaos engineering as a discipline has its
very solid principles or or as you can
say,
test principles
tested over time by all the sides
that you need to be able to run-in
production. You need to be able to,
you know, run various events,
etcetera, etcetera. By now, that is true. We
found that
people practicing chaos generally often tend to use
the tool in mixed ways.
They use it as a testing tool for
carrying out simple failure testing with very, very,
very defined expectations on what happens when you
run a product.
But they also can use it to run
things in a freestyle exploratory way
where you're learning about the system. You don't
have you you basically don't have a set
expectation. You're just trying to see what is
happening. Of course, you have some hypothesis, but
then you're you're
okay to learn about it, and you're doing
it in an environment that is very close
to production but not production itself. Yeah. All
this evolution around shifting
right and testing in production
is great,
but after people started adopting
the cloud native paradigm, started rearchitecting their applications,
testing our Kubernetes as the deployment environment of
choice. There are too many things happening at
once,
and the people
aware of our organizations, we are not confident
to, you know, carry out chaos only in
production.
But they still need chaos to test out
the
efficacy of what they're trying to build. So
they want to do it in pre production
in the roundhouse.
And
and when they are doing that, they wanted
some aids,
things
like probes, for example. You're carrying out
an experiment.
You're injecting a fault. You also want to
see what is happening as the fault is
getting injected
and what is happening part might not be
manual all the time. We have talked about
observability here.
People might be looking at their peering into
their
observability dashboards
getting information. But sometimes, they're just running it
as a background service, injecting faults,
random times, scheduling tools on their clusters.
They also want to factor in what's happening
in their environment even as they do that
fault. So that needed to be built in
into the experiment itself,
the steady state hypothesis validation.
So that was another interesting thing. So we've
talked about last three years. We've talked about
steady state hypothesis coming into the experiments.
Then the need for
they came up to schedule it
and run a background service of sorts. So
these are new things we learned on new
requirements we got as Litmus was being adopted
in the community.
Then we had a very interesting requirement that
came off to that too.
Basically say,
okay. I have a font,
but the font is very complex
or other I wouldn't call it font. Let's
say, it is a situation that I've encountered
in my environment,
and that situation came about as a result
of some failures happening over a period of
time. It's, like, built up over a period
of time. You can call it chain failures.
Maybe you you had a node that sort
of
went into a degraded state because of some
maintenance activity.
Then you have the other node,
which is probably getting more load or your
parts got rescheduled there.
And then you're hitting a resource insertion problem
on that node.
And you have fewer nodes to work with.
You already have one in degraded state.
So your applications will take time to get
scheduled. There will be addictions.
All these kind of problems
sort of get built up over time. So
let's say we're assimilating those kind of scenarios,
how can I do it?
With Litmus, when we started out, we were
able to inject faults,
standalone
faults at a given point of time. But
now we needed the ability to string together
multiple
issues or faults to give a larger scenario
that
you would experience and then find out how
your data has behaved. That gave rise to
what we call as the workflows.
And in the next case, we did get
a glimpse of it in the last
proper discussion as well, but, clearly, we will
still elaborate a little bit more, actually, the
different ways of creating new workflows.
Then all this was great.
Now
I have decided to practice chaos. I understood
what it is and all that, but
there are a lot of clusters that they
had, lot of test or staging in grounds,
as you can call it, dev clusters.
And I find it tedious
to go and install
a set of microservices in each of those
clusters and then carry out chaos individually, monitor
them. I would need something more simpler to
do it. That's when I brought in the
the chaos center
of the request portal as we call it,
where you can attach
other clusters
or register them into the portal,
and you have some agents resetting those clusters
to carry out the chaos process and give
you some visibility on a centralized location.
So these are requirements that came in organically,
sort of
not exactly the sequence that I'm talking about
right now, but these were were things that
we gathered from the community and we built
in. And since there were a lot of
changes that went in, we thought it's worth
doing a major version upgrade.
Litmus was
was one dot two, one dot three, and
so on, and we hit one dot 13.
And then we thought, okay. There
are lot of changes coming in, so we
should move it to the
next version and do a major version upgrade.
So the version upgrade is
sort of reflects
or is a notion of
features rather than being completely all new version
of it, which doesn't work with what was
on there. It's completely
backward compatible. People can continue to use Litmus
with purely
the operator and the case resources as they
were.
But
the portal is probably
something that we will invest time on to
make it easier for folks to carry a
chaos engineering in a simpler way and a
scalable way,
etcetera. So and all the new features that
I talked about,
some of them are directly implemented within the
portal, and some of them are not really
portal related. They just went in into the
infrastructure itself,
the bank and orchestration infrastructure of
Chaos itself. So these are the things that
we will
try to go through today in in some
detail.
And I've just pulled up my demo environment,
which I created some time back. So there
might be some real chaos that we might
see naturally happening.
So I hope the demo gods
are with me today. So with that bit
of introduction,
let me share my screen.
Yeah. Awesome.
Alright.
So this is the Litmus portal,
and I will just log out to start
afresh.
And if I pull my
lens
IDE,
which I'm using.
And I have
sort of added these clusters into the lens
just to show you
what the parts that are running, what are
the microservices that we are running as part
of
you can create different users now.
Litmus, what do we call it? The the
chaos center.
And
so this piece this dashboard that you see
is
the first page that you're going to come
with the home page, which tells you some
past history, some past workflow runs, what are
the agents that have connected here,
etcetera. It also gives you an option to
schedule new workflows.
And
I think my lens is up right now.
So let me go ahead and show you
what are the parts that are running.
I have the Litmus namespace here.
You can see these parts. Out of these,
the Litmus portals are both front end and
MongoDB
from the control plane.
So this is what is powering this
portal. This is this one. The components that
the UI just call it as portal.
The server is a GraphQL server,
it also has an all server
embedded within it. And there is more to
store all your peers'
operation details.
And what we have here, the other ones,
the exporter, the operator, the event tracker,
subscriber,
or control. These are
part of your
agent infrastructure or
the deployment that will run-in the environment where
you want chaos performed.
So you could have just these three
once these three components with the checkboxes
to run the chaos center,
and you can go ahead and add agents,
which will run the other unchecked
the the components with unchecked boxes.
So the operator is at the core and
reconciles the chaos resources, the chaos engine, the
chaos experiment,
etcetera.
So chaos experiment is a template that describes
the fault. The chaos engine is the one
that maps
an application instance or an intra component with
a particular fault
and also provides scope for defining the steady
state validation and other properties.
The subscriber is the one that speaks to
the portal server
and
helps track progress of workflows
in the portal.
And the workflow controller here is an Rawkode
workflow controller,
which is the one that is
helping us execute the workflows or the steps
within a workflow,
which is RBO because of its
immense capabilities
in sequencing or ordering
actions within a workflow. So you could do
things in parallel, you can do in sequence,
and you can define a lot of other
characteristics.
You can do
cleanups, conditional
retention of parts, a lot of flexibility. So
we did not reinvent the wheel, and we've
brought on Rawkode as a workflow engine. Of
course, instrumented with some Litmus images, so we
understand Litmus API.
So this is an add on. There will
be other ways of running workflows, which is
going to be a native way of learning
of doing it as workflows.
And there'll be other tools that one might
want to integrate with it for period of
time that we take on.
You know, it also
the architecture
is being modularized
to add workflow
controllers of choice. So right now, by default,
we have Rawkode
that's coming up into Rawkode.
And this folder is a Prometheus export for
chaos to show chaos metrics. Event tracker helps
in event triggered chaos. You could set up
some policies on when you want to run
chaos experiments, maybe based on some actions on
your cluster.
Let's say when you upgrade an app, you
want some sanity runs,
and we would set up an event tracking
policy
to identify that there has been an app
upgrade, so we basically got a large kiosk.
What kiosk to do there is something that
you can describe via annotations.
So that's something that we can take a
look later.
So the Litmus agents is the concept we
were talking about.
There's something called self agent here.
So
the self agent is
the
represents
the agent on the local cluster. That is
the cluster where the chaos center has been
deployed.
So it automatically registers itself as
a chaos environment.
So you can start doing chaos against microservices
living inside
of this particular cluster.
Yep. And I have another agent that's added
here. I'll show you the process of adding
an agent Mhmm.
Which is another cluster which has only agent
components,
and there's a Kafka state. So it's running
there. That's the demo that I think we
covered last
Rawkode episode, so we'll probably not do the
same demo. But I'll just show you how
you can connect an agent.
Now let's go ahead and
take a look at some of the other
sidebar items and what the improvements have been.
So there is a chaos hub.
So this is the integrated or embedded chaos
hub within the portal.
You know about the chaos hub. It is
some kind of a one marketplace
that has the experiments of products listed,
and they are categorized by different
categories,
different
kinds of classification.
The generic experiments are the standard Kubernetes parts,
source network, or other defaults.
Mhmm. Then there are AWS
categories.
There's
application specific
categories,
and we also have VMware experiments that we
serve. And I will talk about chaos against
non Kubernetes entities
from the portal, which is something that is
new,
something that we improved upon since
last time.
So
that's one feature.
Going back
to talking about the hub,
you can connect
either a public kiosk hub or you can
connect a private one as well. Let's say
you you have some kind of a aircraft
and a company you're operating out of,
you can connect to local get repositories.
It just needs to have experiment
entries within the deposit in a particular directory
structure
as you can see in this repository called
as the chaos charts.
So the chaos charts
here is the canonical back end for the
hub,
and
it has
all these
experiments listed inside the charts folder.
These are not the health charts. We just
call them the litmus charts,
and each of this is a category.
And you could coincide that by individual experiment.
Each experiment in each category is defined
by some
information placed inside of the chart service portion.
The other way,
which provides the source for all the information
printed on the on the hub. Very similar
to the way an operator top is built.
We took inspiration from that and created something
that's very similar with Chaos Charts.
You could
form this and place your own experiments and
connect it as a private kiosk as well.
You would use experiments from here to pick
and create
new workforce.
So that is in your development that we
did here,
And this came about
as we were working with enterprises
and organizations which
prefer their own sources. Of course, they would
commit stuff into upstream, give us some and
we're comfortable with it, but you would have
local sources to experiment stuff.
The other capability
came in the form of the analytics dashboard.
So
one of the requirements
that we had is to be able to
ascertain
the progress we are making in our kiosk
practice.
Let's say you had some experiments
against some microservices.
You got a result,
and we would need to be
and we would want to compare our results
over a period of time. How would you
do that? How would you put a metric
or a number against
the experimentation
process that you did? So we have something
called resilience score. I think we've stressed about
it in the previous episode. There have been
some improvements there, so we'll talk about it
when we get to running the workflow. So
you can compare workflows here in the workflow
dashboard
tab
of analytics
where you're essentially comparing
different
workflows that you ran over a period of
time,
right, and what scores
they achieved,
what resident scores they achieved.
And there's also capability
to do application monitoring,
not so much analyzing results, but looking at
how application
changes behavior changes as we go along.
And this is something very similar to what
you would do with, let's say,
a Grafana CloudWatch or something like that. So
you have a data source.
We support the latest phase where you can
connect that, and you can create a very
simple application dashboard.
It uses Blockly,
and
the JSON structure
for the dashboards are very similar to how
we would construct Grafana dashboard. We
have some features coming in close to our
quote that would help with
creating new panels
or creating new dashboards
from the portal, but we need to sort
of construct
and then upload them.
So that is about that's the improvements that
we've made in the analytics section.
So
that's something. And we we got that requirement
because
there are folks who wanted
to sort of view what happens to their
application
within the portal without having to move to,
let's say,
a different application or different browser to open
up some other app.
How much you use this is left to
the user because a lot of people already
have observability infrastructure in place.
They already have
application dashboards set up,
and they would only need
metrics from the kiosk framework to be able
to correlate what's happening to application
when you start up.
Consume metrics
from the Litmus side.
But for folks who've not really set up
something
already,
maybe
they can use of the make make use
of the application dashboards.
It also has
more
intuitive
data corresponding to the chaos. It tells you
when a chaos experiment started, ended, what is
the score, etcetera,
when you hover on the graphs
of the
applications.
So that's something that we added in recent
times and something that's that I just need
to report.
So as far as the settings goes,
this is a standard accounts
page where you set
your preferences.
Next one is for teams.
So one of the useful
features
of the chaos center
is
about how you can invite other folks
in your organization or in your team to
collaborate with you on chaos.
So you might have people looking at results.
You might have people constructing new workflows and
running them. You have people just gathering some
stats,
etcetera?
So you can invite you can create users
and
invite them into the team in different roles
as
editors, as as users of
all all types,
and
you can collaborate
with them Yep. For GA. The
the other feature here is
for GitOps. This is something that we created
in Pixabnance.
So, Rawkode, this is very interesting and
we sort of wanted to play the best
practices of GitOps
that's being used for app delivery
into the chaos engineering practice.
That is one way of looking at it,
One requirement that we sort of encountered.
The other one was
how do we integrate with the standard
app delivery GitOps flow.
So you have
are we saving your plugs or tree in
the in configuration management
spinnaker that you set up.
And there's a change in the source
of your application that or maybe there's an
image that has been pushed. You've set up
some automated
monitoring and
upgrades.
So your tool is basically going to go
ahead and
sync your source with the cluster. It's going
to go and update the
cluster with the latest portion of your app.
And when you do that,
you might want especially when you do this
in staging environments,
which is probably where you might first apply
the the GitOps
upgrade,
the flow, before you promote it to production.
So
when you do that, you might wanna run
some sanity checks
on a
very nearly present staging environment, which mimics production.
You might want to see how this new
change in your application
works, how does it hold up against different
kinds of various scenarios.
So you could run something like a sanity
test,
and
you could create event tracking policies. I think
we mentioned it when looking at these deployments
during its back.
You can set up some policies to ensure
that
your
application undergoes some chaos,
predefined chaos workflows
that it can subscribe to via annotations,
and you will get a result of that
and help you take a better call on
what to do next, whether you promote this
to production or you go fix something,
etcetera.
So
the first part of the GitOps story that
we mentioned is about workflows that you create,
which gets synced into a Git repository. So
if I go ahead and enable GitOps,
and I
basically say, this is the Git repository where
I want my Kiosk artifacts to be sourced
I mean, to be placed as a golden
copy. So whatever workflows that I create here
gets synced to there.
And these workflows, which have been synced to
get and maintained,
can then be subscribed
to by some application,
resulting in a cluster by means of even
tracker policy.
Though it's not a new mandate that you
need this always stored in Git, the artifacts
stored in Git to be able to pull
them and run
for as part of the event triggered in
chaos, it is still good to have it
so that, let's say, event changes and get
the same gets reflected on the portal.
Next time the chaos runs in an automated
fashion because of your event track policies that
you set up here, like, the latest version
of it.
So
these are the various settings, and there's there's
another tab here. It's mostly for a day
to purpose. People who are running in their
own
run their own registries,
which is most likely the case today,
you might want to replace the
images within a workflow with
images coming from your registry so you can
do
changes.
You can make
some
custom changes to the workflow just before you
run it.
So
that that's to ease up,
you know, maintaining your workflows.
So these are the various
features. There's something called usage statistics here. It's
more for
a high level overview
of
how your case management practice is going,
how many users you have on the platform
that are participating in chaos, how many projects
are there, how to what requirements or what
teams or what services,
And then how many agents do you have?
How many workflows you've done? How many have
succeeded or how many have failed?
A lot of that statistics can be viewed
and downloaded as reports
for you to give you some kind of
information
on how things are going.
And
yeah. So we have API
documentation,
which is basically
going to help you to utilize this platform
without necessarily
using the dashboard.
So
that's the
refurpished
portal dashboard for you that's coming up.
At this point,
I'd like to see if there are any
questions
before I talk about the latest phase of
running workflows.
And we we will have some sample applications,
some sample types of these apps that we'll
use to run these workflows.
So are there any questions
at this point?
Yeah. I've got a a couple of questions,
and we've one in the chat that's about
getting started with chaos engineering,
so we can tackle that as well. But
we'll start with the the changes to Litmus
first. So
the this new ability to control agents and
remote clusters,
do you see this being the standard way
now for people to really adopt chaos engineering
by having, like, a centralized chaos center and
reaching out to those clusters? Or do you
see a world where it's really just personal
choice and people,
you know, will still prefer to go down
and deploy each chaos center into their own
clusters? I mean, what's your opinions on that?
Is is there a better way there?
It's a great question.
I think these are for the way for
our community interaction,
we see that there are different personas
using
the chaos. Engineering has become
sort of popular really popular in the last,
let's say, year or so. And not to
say that it's not being practiced early in
the yesterday's, but somehow there was this perception
that this, you know, dedicated
group of experts sitting somewhere carrying out a
game day.
The SREs
who really are the ones with engineering that
from that perspective,
it is sort of changing.
There are more people getting involved at various
levels
of the organization or various levels of app
delivery, I would say. There are these SREs
who are doing it in a very controlled
way. The game tends to be very
popular way of playing it. Then there are
other folks,
let's say, engineers,
while looking at it, we're looking at chaos
and sort of adopting it as the de
facto way to do
exploratory failure testing,
if you will.
So
the definition of chaos engineering is becoming
a little more broadened, I would say. It's
more like the principles of chaos are being
applied
at different stages.
And, therefore, the consumers of the tool that
provides you the chaos engineering capabilities
are multifold.
And some of them like
centralized
approach to managing chaos.
So they have this mandate and they have
this unknown,
and they say you have these clusters. These
are all staging environments.
You are a group of folks who ensure
that all services getting on to staging
need to be good, need to be validated,
and we need to be able to derive
some meaning out of that validation.
And there's a single place where we need
to collect all that info. I think for
those kind of folks, the
secure center is useful.
But like you said, there might be
practitioners of chaos, more advanced practitioners of chaos
who might think, okay.
I'm comfortable doing things as hand charts and
templates.
I manage everything by myself. I choose to
do it on specific clusters as a standalone
deployment
or installation,
and I'm able to make observations myself
and probably have my own tooling to glean
results from whatever key or service or other
glean data that you are putting
out and need not be packaged a certain
way. I don't need any help in inferencing
data
that also that person also exists.
And the way we see
the portal of center is, of course, it
has a UI component dashboard,
but there are APIs. There's an API server
which
is
pretty useful and becoming more powerful in time.
So you can do a lot of things
using CLI or correcting book.
API,
can have a GraphQL client in Python or
Golang that you are making use of to
construct useful faults,
run things,
maybe
consume analytics data,
etcetera. So
to answer that question, to summarize, I think
both
will coexist from some time.
The the consumers of the care center of
one persona and the others who are directly
go with them on a per cluster installation
and
manage things their own way. Things both will
continue to exist for some time.
We had a lot of people asking for
this capability,
is by the sort of thought this this
could
get to a get to a specific audience
and help them
get started with chaos. Maybe this is
an easy way to sort of break that
barrier and start doing experiments
because it's feels pretty simple to construct. It's
about first around them, view what's happening, and
things like that. Then once
you have that familiarity,
you'll probably no longer need this or you'll
probably just use the API service. You guys
have so directly without having to use the
dashboard.
So, yeah,
I think both exist.
Alright. Thank you for that. I I think
we're seeing this pattern across
the cloud native landscape. I know a lot
of get ups tooling now is is starting
to do that idea of remote management and
centralizing your get operations as well. So I
think this ties in really nicely with that
approach,
as, you know, we're starting to turn the
corner on organizations having lots of small clusters
instead of massive large clusters. And the the
remote management aspect there is is
appealing and just really getting a lot of
steam.
Great answer. Thank you. Okay.
I have And on the other question Yeah.
Go ahead. No. It's okay. Go for it.
The other question on getting
started.
So the product docs
of Litmus or as we call it as
we call it,
it's
there here.
This helps you to get started with Litmus
one topics purely
based on the kiosk operator,
with the kiosk, CRs,
and executing it in individual clusters,
etcetera.
If you are happy
beta testers
for Litmus2.co,
you you can take a look at the
Litmus docs that we have on Netify.
That is the Litmus data Netify app. Then
go to the
master version.
You can see a lot of information that's
being put here.
And this is one of the things that
we are
we are at right now,
trying to improve the documentation and put more
details
of how we can use the
itdoes2.o.
Sorry about that. So
this is a good place to start,
and
I will recommend you to take a look
at it if want to get started with.
The studio in case you just
want to
run the bare minimum experimentation
with the case operator, the
dogs, or the mosquitoes, whatever is the one
Awesome. Thank you for that as well. I
have one more question, and then I'll let
you jump on to the the workflow thing
that you said you were going to cover.
With regards to the data sources, what kind
of remote data sources are supported there?
As of today, it is Prometheus
Okay.
That that we support.
There is
Prometheus exported from Litmus that is being
used well sometime.
So
you could add Prometheus
data source, start managing your start creating panels
to view your application behavior, then
you could sort
of get your best metrics to the same
data source and superimpose them against your app
metrics
to see what's happening to your app during
chaos.
Yeah. I think it would be really interesting
if we here's my future request for you
now, Kartik. But, you know, when we do
chaos I speak from my own experience. I
won't say we. When I do chaos engineering,
you know, I'm generally trying to see how
my app is for customers during terms of
turbulence and chaos. And I wonder like if
we could have Google Analytics as a data
source and be able to actually see,
you know, JavaScript rendering time and, you know,
time to the page being available, the data
come down and all that. I think that
would be a really interesting insight to how
the chaos affects my customer's point of view.
That's a great feature request. I think it
makes a lot of sense.
Yes. I think that's something that we would
be very happy to
take control. Thanks for that feedback.
Yes. I think Yeah. I'll
make sure I open an issue on the
the GitHub for that, so don't worry. Okay.
Do you wanna take us away with the
workflow change? Oh. Oh, sorry. On you go.
On that note,
this is where you can create
issues on Litmus. So it's like Litmus care
slash Litmus is the repository.
Please feel free to create issues here, and
we will definitely
get back on them. Be happy to consider
and feel free to put your thoughts there
on those issues. Thank you. And, of course,
pull request welcome. Right? There.
So you could start off a new I
mean, you could participate in a discussion, start
up a new discussion thread.
That that works as well.
Nice.
Alright. So
let's go to the workflow creation part.
And
before we do that, let me show you
what I have.
There is an application
called as
Bank of Anthos, which you might be familiar
with, provided by Google Cloud Platform.
Very interesting microservices app
has different kinds of services,
different platforms being used to create these microservices,
Python, Paint Java,
etcetera. And
they have all
the services to give you the experience
of a banking
app.
So we have Bank of Anthos with the
balance and your net shares and has option
for you to deposit funds or make payments,
etcetera.
So it's it's a cool
example
to get started with for chaos to see
what happens.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to inhibit
network traffic
on on the balance reader app.
So that's one of the application. One of
the sub pieces,
following
this detail, I'm able to read this balance
because of the balance reader.
And
also, when we make payments,
it needs to see how much balance we
have in our account before it makes the
payment.
So it tries to speak to this microservice,
the payment service, whatever, tries to speak to
the balance service.
So what we're do is create a %
packet drop. You could call this, like, a
black hole.
Basically,
nothing goes through to that service
and see how that impacts our experience,
how it causes a degradation in the user
experience. Let's say, I'm a customer of Panthers,
how it impacts them.
But with this, we will also see
how you can the intent of this part
of the demonstration is to see how you
can construct workflow by picking the
parts of experiments
from the integrated
chaos hub
and how you can set some
how you can tune it for how long
you want to run it, etcetera.
So let me go ahead and click on
schedule
workflow.
I'm going to select self agent
because
the back panels resides in the same cluster
where my portal is installed on. So happens
to be self agent.
So let me go ahead and click next.
So there are different options here. Some of
these might have been you might have taken
a look at them before, but they've been
improved and made, especially the section here on
creating your work program hub. So in this
drop down,
I have
the chaos hub, the single
public chaos hublets embedded here.
So I basically go ahead and select this,
and I give it a name,
Rawkode or Anthos
black.
And
I have the option of
going and selecting
a new experiment. Let me add a new
experiment.
I'm interested in network loss, so let me
select that from this category.
I have a printer that you can use.
So once I select this,
I can go and tune
this experiment.
So, basically, click here
and
I can see details
that
basically show what have I taken
the experiment from and what is the name
of the experiment and etcetera.
When I say next,
I have the option of
indicating the application against which we will do
this part.
Now this is something like asset discovery,
we can call it. In other in other
words, this discovering the microservices
on your Kubernetes cluster. The agent performs this
task, the subscriber, to be more precise.
So I'm looking at application in the volume
space, which is where my
background resides.
There are also the namespaces. This is too
much you can see.
And the balance rate is of kind deployment,
and it has
an application
label
called app equals to balance figure. That's the
one that I'm going to target.
Annotation check here is a way to further
do
filtering of applications or to increase
blast radius control.
If you have multiple applications
that share a common
label because that's how you deploy it, they
will all have a common label.
You are going to select just one of
them for some reason. You can annotate it
with a specific annotation,
and then you can force witness to check
for that deployment which carries the annotation
before it does the but it's not mandatory.
Mind you, I just have one instance
of balance readers, right, the annotation check to
false.
There's a cleanup policy here,
which tells me that I want to keep
my bots or I want to clean them.
I want to keep them
because that's how I can see logs on
the portal. The the workflow visualization graph in
the portal gives you the opportunity to pull
the logs for the experiment that is
just executed,
and it will be able to pick logs
from a live
or an existing part of the cluster.
We do not store the logs in the
chaos centers. We just retrieve it on demand.
So I would like to keep those parts
in order to show you those logs. There
are also options to set node selectors. For
example,
like you may all know, when Litmus executes
it for, runs it as a Kubernetes job.
And you might have references on how you
want to run this
this job, where you want to run it,
etcetera. If you have a specific note, there
is this practice that's there.
They put on business applications on certain nodes.
They have dedicated some nodes to run their
main
application services
either by making use of affinity policies or
tolerations and things like that. And they have
another node
dedicated to running some third party services or
tooling, so to say. In case you're just
doing like that, you can provide the notes
selected
for those details.
So let me click next.
So at this point,
I have the option
of adding a probe.
Probe
is
a way
to validate
steady state hypothesis, and there are different kinds
of probes. We will come to that in
the next
workflow that I run, which is against another
service.
For now,
let me not do any validation. Just more
interested in just doing the workflow and seeing
the fault.
So let me click next. And this is
before you have to tune the duration of
your your chaos
and adding other variables. There are different tunables
that particular
experiment supports that you can see in the
experiment documentation.
So let's say, for network loss,
you can see that there are different
tables here
that you can provide in case you're interested
in doing that. Many of them are optional.
So you can provide
that by adding a new case.
And I'm interested in
providing the just the defaults and running with
them. So click finish.
Revert schedule is to keep the chaos resource
and not
clean it up.
This is what the chaos engine resource,
which is set to false.
And when I go ahead and say next,
so this is the step
which you might already be aware of to
provide the criticality or weight
of a particular experiment within a workflow,
and this is going to influence the final
resiliency score.
The points that we provide here multiplied by
the success factor of the experiment.
Success factor is retrieved as
the execution completes.
So you have
a percentage success for that part depending on
how many probes were successful or how many
negative checks
within the experiment were successful. When say negative
check, it's about
let's say you have a pre chaos check.
I want my services to be in so
and so state before carry
out the chaos
because I don't want to do chaos against
an already degraded system.
And then after you
run far, maybe there is some particular state
you're looking for,
and let's check that you can do. These
are pre and post class checks. It's also
part of the steady state hypothesis validation.
So depending upon how these checks went and
how the probes went even as your fault
happens, something there's something called as a continuous
mode
in the probe,
which happens in parallel as you do the
fault. So it checks real time how your
app behaves, not just the recovery
as in the native post year sticks.
So all those checks contribute
to you getting a success factor.
We call it as a post success percentage.
It's anywhere between zero to 100%.
And that
multiplied
by the points that you gave for a
given experiment.
And the summation of this for all the
experiments you have within a workflow divided by
the total points
gives you the resilience score. It's a metric
that helps you to understand where you stand
with respect to resilience
for a particular scenario or workflow
for a given app. So this is the
one that connects an application or an infrastructure
component
with a scenario and then tries to try
to figure out the scope that you have
for it. And then that is something you
can use because it is quantified.
You will be able to compare it over
time to see how it has improved or
maybe debated
or even what you want to see, how
it changes across infrastructure.
So when you run the same form against
an app deployed, let's say, it's JFK application
deployed with a particular storage class
on that particular c nine
or a particular type of node versus when
you repeat the same thing with some other
environment completely
different,
you will be able to see some differences
sometimes,
which are very instructive. So you're learning more
about the system that way. So
this is going to help in that process.
So I'm going to give all the points
because there's
no real other points in this workflow, this
one. So I just give it all points.
I click next.
At this point,
I can schedule it once or I can
schedule it repeatedly.
This is standard crop
where you go ahead and keep running those
workflows anyway.
I'm going to just try it once.
So at this point, I can
view the YAML
to see some summary of
what is there.
The YAML is maybe of
it may be familiar to you. It might
look very much like the Rawkode is, just
the kind of workflow.
And we have two steps. The first step
to install the template
for a font.
This describes the font itself,
and it is pulled from the hub
that is integrated into the portal.
And the next step is to launch the
engine, which connects your font with your application.
So you have
something here of interest. We can see there
is balance reader
in default namespace, and we have the duration
here.
So we have the little drop packet loss
percentage.
By default, we use
or we assume that the cluster is docker
and this is the socket part, but that
will be different. You can change it to
container d and give a different socket part,
etcetera.
It makes use of the runtime APIs to
inject the network for this case. Let me
finish the flow of the result
and
go to a workflow. So this is going
to run.
And there will be some parts,
transient parts created
in your witness namespace,
which are now doing these tasks of putting
the experiment template, the hop and installing it,
and then launching the kiosk inject to trigger
the actual fault injection.
So that can be visualized
in this particular visualization.
There's also a table view that
you can use.
And
as the experiment
gets underway,
you will be able to see the impact
caused on Bank of Anthos.
So right now,
we're just getting
initialized
with the actual font.
So add back to that. This looks good.
You can see balances.
Alright. We're able to create it. We're able
to deposit funds
and do all these
activities.
Very soon,
I will not be able to read this
balance
as the yeah.
You can see I made a deposit right
now.
They cannot see how much
it increased. So that's
it's not good. You would not like to
see these kind of things happen in real
time, especially with banks.
So the next step, let's say, you make
payment.
You won't be able to make it because
you're not able to pay the balance.
So this has been deliberately set up, and
then we
do not have any
yeah. You can see the payment failed. It
was not able to proceed.
In fact, there's a a bigger exception that
you can see in the logs,
and this
is something that you would we really want
to avoid for your applications.
So we've deliberately set it up without
the
mitigation.
So you will see the error. It just
illustrate
the font in progress.
So we are going to do this. We
are going to keep at it for some
time.
Sixty seconds as you saw in the
engine
manifest.
And once that is over,
the balance will be available again. We will
stop the key hazard, revert it,
And
you will be able to see that things
are restored. And the experiment makes a check
to see if it is restored, if it
is healthy
before it actually concludes.
If it finds out that post the injection
was not able to recover or let's say
the self healing in your infrastructure is not
working,
then that's a alarm bell,
and you will have the notifications to go
ahead and check. You can send notifications based
on from these metrics,
but you can have other means of verifying
this, but have your own server team. We
have some alerts coming in into the Kubernetes
portal, but that's going to be post
to Rawkode.
So this is about
how your application
came up. So let me go ahead and
reload the
app once again, and I think I should
be able to read
my balance because the
duration has elapsed. Yeah. This looks great.
And
this is just going to finish its post
chaos checks
and complete the experiment. You will see there
you will see a pause here in this
experiment
because
it actually
ran
successfully. The for ran successfully in the
pre and post year six were good, but
we did not really validate the behavior of
microfantas
as the part was happening, which I think
is pretty important. So in the next workflow
that we run using a different technique, we
will upload the AR file instead of constructing
the workflow
through the Maya,
the port of the integrated tier store.
Integration intent also added. You can see the
logs here.
We retain those parts to be able to
see the logs.
So you will find those details here.
The kiosk result is the resource that carries
details of the kiosk. It says process percentage
is hundred.
Therefore and since we have given 10 points,
this was the only quality that has score
of as well.
But this doesn't have a validation in bonding,
But you can see some details. There's a
history of cost of pay terms. We can
repeat this. It will be some historical
information.
And
we will also have details
of
let me just show you that
on my console
of the successful injection report status
of the
of of your
chaos. Let's see. This is Chaos result.
Looking at the Litmus namespace.
Let's see there's some information here.
This was the application against which we did
the chaos,
and the status of chaos says reverted
and the kind of
application that we actually get the 42 is
is a part happens to be a part,
which most likely it is. There will be
a
it could be a disk or an instance,
user instance, whatever. You'll be able to see
the current status,
which is, like, generally useful.
And there are some events, as we can
see here,
and also events on the the kiosk engine
resource too.
So we have some
kind of observability
around Kubernetes events to be able to track
the progress of the experiments that way as
well.
So that is something
you could do, one way of creating workflows.
The other way
is to create a template. So I I
I could
go ahead
and schedule workflow,
select the agent to reach which you wanted
to chaos,
then you could
basically select
create a new workflow by cloning an existing
template. You could go to the individual workflows,
the schedules
tab,
and take a look at all that you
ran.
And then you go ahead and create this
template out of it and provide some name
and description.
Next time you want to run this full
previous template,
edit it for your builds and proceed with
chaos.
That is one simple way of running it.
But let's say you want to store it
in your git repository,
you could do that. So let me say
I set up
a Git repository to Chrome, and here, I'm
just gonna provide
a simple
repository on
my side.
And
now I have this
connect that I will do to this repository.
I can provide access token or I can
set up SSH key.
Again, I can provide this
to my
repository. You can just go ahead and
provide my SSH keys,
and you will be able to go ahead
and
create a sync workflows here
whenever you construct it from your request port.
So that is one quick
way of ensuring that there's a golden copy
of your workflows
in your repository.
So you can go ahead and maintain it
there.
You can change it and get synced in
the portal. So in the interest of time,
let me move up go ahead to the
next
workflow
creation type. So here, I'm just going to
select the agent, and you can import the
workflow
from the
YAML that you might have in your workspace
on your laptop or
at some such location.
You can just or you have these machines.
You can just pull that and
import your YAML. In this case, I'm going
to select
a kiosk workflow that I'm going to use
to create an engine for
an easy to instance.
So this is one of the things
that I wanted to sort of highlight in
our chaos journey.
So a lot of organizations have
hybrid economics.
Either they are in the process of adopting
Kubernetes,
migrating to Kubernetes,
or they have already adopted it for some
services while they continue to operate some other
services
And
they would have they'll try to do chaos
against
those components as well, not just
targeting pods, doing pod level and node level
figures for Kubernetes nodes and pods, but also
act against
what you could many lines of instances,
if you may. So
there are different parts you can do on
that. You can
do things like taking down the instance or
disconnecting
disks attached to it. Or you can cause
some CPU burn or memory burn inside the
VM.
Can kill processes.
You can inject latencies against data,
networks there.
All sorts of you can do service for
the kiosk for services running inside.
We use a lot of things that you
would want to do there as well, and
they would want to have the same
tooling
location from where you run all that, have
the same experience in running chaos against non
Kubernetes entities
while you
still run the application business logic in Kubernetes.
So it was as big as a Kubernetes
microservices
app.
So if you take a look
at
if I have so
here it is.
Let me go ahead and try to
show you some slides. Yes.
Here it is. You can take a look
at this. It means it's going to run
on Kubernetes, but it is going to make
use of the provider
API
to do
fault against some cloud infrastructure.
As long as it is accessible,
you have set up the access for it
using secrets.
You will be able to leverage the API
provided by these
cloud
platforms.
Many of them have very defined SPK, which
you can make use of to
launch the kiosk. You can either construct a
new experiment that way or you can make
use of existing
experiments to do that. This is one such.
So we're going to do chaos against one
of these instances. So I have some easy
two instances
running some
application.
A beams a beams scopes.
I'm sorry. Beave Beaveworks
SOCKSHOP
microservices application.
And that
is basically hosted
on
one of these
worker nodes.
And we're going to bring that down and
see what happens to the performance
of my workshop.
So this is some chaos happening on my
dashboard.
Yeah. It's a funny Grafana theme.
So
let me go ahead and
should last five minutes.
So
and you mentioned about
statistic hypothesis
validation that you'd like to do.
So I have the front end service,
which is showing me some
queries per second, some transactions,
two hundred hours per second.
Maybe this is going to go down
when I do the chaos,
but I expect you to come back up
within specific period of time. Sometimes you sort
of
consign yourself to the fact that, okay, there
is going to be a different performance when
we do this,
but I'm going to test the
main plan for recovery.
I'm going to test how quickly my system
recovers, how quickly it comes back to good
operational state and the metrics become optimal once
again. So we have that kind of a
validation report to do along with an availability
check to see if the service under question
is always available.
So those things we want to be in
into the experiment.
And
for that, let me just take you to
this flow rate workflow. So this was another
means of running the workflow or rather constructing
it. I have it already, so I've just
imported it from my workspace.
And then you can go ahead and tune
it same way that you tuned.
And if at all you did tune
something here,
either you you can do it here. You
can do it by editing the YAML.
And in case you change something,
let's say, you want to
keep the duration of this not just for
thirty seconds but slightly
longer,
I I can choose to do it as
I go to thirty five.
And I want to see what is the
latest
URL of the Wave source app.
And for that, let me try and see
what my IP is
from the EC two instances.
And so so if I look at the
detail here,
this is my public address.
So I'm just going to copy it. I'm
going to put it in my
probes that we have. There's an HTTP probe,
which is going to continuously
verify every
two seconds
to see if I can see the 200
okay
on this
endpoint.
And I'm also doing a performance recovery check
within
a period of
let's say, there are two retries with one
second tool. So let's say, within
a two second period,
I'm interested on this also time out here.
So each try is going to wait for
some time if the response is not found.
So
within
the recovery period, you want to specify recovery
period. You want
the performance to come back to some number.
Right? It it may may not be right.
You can see there's a probably this end
point. There's a query that we gave, and
then there is a
comparative that we've defined. So this, you can
think of as some kind of service that
are indicated as a line,
and the cutoff against that can be your
service level objective. Sometimes service level objectives might
not be as simple as a one microservice
metric. It might be
a larger
data point that you're looking for from your
platform. But you would be able to
sort of represent that intention,
that check
around as well as also using the box.
So now that now now that we have
all this information, let me go ahead and
save
whatever changes
I made here.
And then
we provide the criticality and just go ahead
and execute it. So when we do this,
you will see the same couple of steps
being performed.
You will see the installation of the experiment,
and then the case engine will be launched
to
trigger the instance
stopping.
So here,
you will be able to see
the worker one
stopping
and eventually going to stop state and stay
there for thirty five seconds or whatever. He
did repeat it.
And you'll also see in the process,
the application is going to go down,
and the metrics are going to drop.
And we will be able to
make these checks from within the experiment from
and give you a word of it and
give you a post success percentage
Let me go ahead and yeah. You can
see that this is stopping,
and it's eventually going to go to stop
state. So
this is one way of acting upon
you can call an out of band way
of acting upon cloud resources.
But you might also want to do experiments
to
eat up resources across
network forwards,
services running within VMs.
And that's something that will be added on.
That's also an improvement from last time. We
have new experiment categories which make use of
agents running within this VM
to carry your forms there
and give you that, in fact, yes, capabilities
in addition to what we already had with,
let's say, instance failures or disk failures and
things like that. So,
yeah, you can see that it has stopped.
I will not be able to load WaveSox
anymore.
And you can do this not just against
is it for instance, is contributing to Kubernetes
cluster? You can do this on any
not least for instance.
You can do things by tag.
And if you're doing it by tag and
you have multiple instances
that are identified by the tag,
you can provide a percentage of instances that
you want to bring down by instance, affected
percentage.
And you can also, I
basically,
provide a flag for whether the
instances that you are killing are part of
managed node group or more. If it is,
then the recovery or the
health post case health checks that we perform
will be slightly different.
You can see that this is done,
and
the application is gone down. So this red
area that you're seeing here
is coming because of the Litmus
annotation that we have, the Litmus metric and
it has a Griffin annotation to tell you
this is when it gets actually happening.
So this is the front end ops
going down and
coming up, etcetera.
And
you will end up
seeing the results of this validation. Sometimes,
your application recovery might be fast.
Sometimes, it might be slow.
It really depends on that. And finally,
you will have the details presented inside the
kiosk reset, what happened to the individual
probes, whether they succeeded or failed,
and you will be able to get a
metric.
So there are different kinds of Litmus metrics.
The weighted experiment is a useful one to
show you the period when the chaos
ran, and it has injection
time and for the details.
Lot of labels, you can see there's something
called context.
This is basically
details or some metadata of why you're running
this particular experiment.
You can basically add new labels
just to give you an overall idea.
So this is how you go ahead and,
yeah, you can see that this experiment failed.
As
anticipated,
the availability check failed, so did the performance
checks.
So that's something that
was expected.
So
this is a new capability doing chaos against
non Kubernetes
entities and also being able to do that
for both kinds. There are
for example, there is a workflow that you
could use to
do CPU or memory hop
from your
be on your VMs,
not so much on pods
or Kubernetes modes. So this is something that
will
that that can be done as well. You
can see there's a reward kiosk step in
addition to what we had in other experiments
to clean up.
Then exchanges
and then
go ahead and run this. So all that
I'm showing you through the dashboard,
all these experiments
can be done by directly invoking the kiosk
engine the one dot x model of running
it with your kiosk operator.
Or if you choose to run with the
kiosk center, which is what is recommended,
you can make use of the APIs
to perform these operations. There'll be some there
we are working on
called worker three.
They have a node exporter
setup,
and you will see some utilization
spike
on on the workers here
for one of these
nodes.
That's a pretty cool new feature.
I really like that. So
it's nice that you can target those AWS
different, you know, kind of vectors rather than
sticking purely within the Kubernetes thing. I assume
this is something that will be expanded over
time to more providers, more clouds, more external
resources. Like, really, there's there's no limit to
to what you can add here. Right?
That's true. You you can actually
take a look at some of the experiments
which are tech review
mode.
So you'll find them
inside your slip.
And you can see there are in the
similar experiments of GCP
and
Azure as well
and for VMware.
And like I said, it's not just
the instance of the other
services that you can target.
So, yes, like I said,
there's a lot of things that we could
add here to make it easy.
One of the reasons we
or one of the advantages of
it being purely
community collaborated and open sources,
chaos means different things to different people.
So they come with their viewpoints,
contribute,
and
sort of really enrich
the library of in terms of what all
materials scenarios can be done and what are
the strategic validations can be done. The the
hypothesis is something that, again, is very
diverse. It is
yep. You can see some spike happening here.
The the
value in a particular field inside of a
customer source, maybe you're in a posters operator,
and you're want monitoring the health of that
deployment,
and that is reflected in some
status field on your CRM.
And you're interested to get that before you
do some other things as part of the
experiment.
That's that's part of the hypothesis.
So there are different ways of
doing checks, and we're also trying to work
with different on adding these probes, different kinds
of probes that you might want to do.
Some of them will be prompt over purely
about consuming
metrics
from Providius. There will be other other
providers that we would like to integrate with
to show the interleaving
as well as to do
validation.
But there are other probes that we can
build. So
all these
different modes of doing them,
when you do them, etcetera. So you can
actually create
if you look at the principles of chaos
here,
there are lot of things which
are true
irrespective of the the model or the usage
general, mean, it's cloud native, not cloud native.
It's great to be able to do validations
as we stay.
Either you do it manually or you build
it into the
automation, into the experiment.
Very real world events to different kind of
forms. There's so many kinds of forms possible
today to try and bring them in.
Running production when you're confident,
and you know the incorrect procedures well. You
have a sort of sign off from all
the stakeholders.
And running continuously because especially this force so
much through
the cloud native one because there's a constant
churn to
provide that end user experience.
You have your services that we that you
roll up as a as a as an
application service provider.
And then there are so many things you're
borrowing from the CNC landscape, from observability, from
storage,
service measures, all sorts of things which are
giving you that end experience
to the user or it helps your SLA
team to maintain that end user experience
in maintaining the the health of your deployments.
All those things
keep changing continuously,
so you keep upgrading them. Kubernetes itself,
you keep upgrading.
So you would like to know how things
change. So it's important to run these experiments
continuously and have a framework to automate them,
set up scheduled chaos maybe.
And two,
minimization of last year is select the right
summaries,
like, component
for the right duration,
in the right namespace,
etcetera.
I have the ability to specify all that.
So we're looking at
taking these principles and
bringing them on to Rikmus
along with a few other games,
like GitOps and
workflows to stitch together scenarios and few other
settings to give you an end to end
platform for case engineering. But there's
a lot of improvement
that can be made yet
in terms of features and
in terms of capabilities because
chaos is getting, as we speak, is evolving.
For example, people are eventually into security chaos
today to to find out vulnerabilities.
So in fact, being able to run some
services successfully
without
the right restrictions being placed on running them
is also a chaos test. So there are
different ways of looking at it. So
the the the scope really, like you mentioned,
is is endless. The the lot of capabilities
that we brought in, we're we're looking forward
to the feedback
and contributions pouring in from the community
and being the scenes in project helps.
There's a lot of good
feedback
that we received over time,
which has helped us
to make these improvements.
And a lot of good contributions coming in
from community. A lot of the probes work
was contributed before from Red Hat, so which
is awesome.
And really looking forward to continuing this
journey
on improving the
experiments
and the capabilities
and
hope to be on another
discussion on on Rawkode with
more improvements as we go.
Awesome. I think that that's something
that takes it to close on what they
had in mind to discuss today.
That was perfect. There there are a lot
of really cool updates to love there with
Litmus. I'm really looking forward to the the
new version and playing with some of those
features.
And I love that you can have almost
tied it all together at the end there
with the mention of the CNCF and contributions,
but we will be doing a
contributing to Litmus on Cloud Native TV
a week on Friday with one of your
colleagues, I believe. So people should check that
out if they want want to know how
to contribute to the Litmus project as well.
Alright, Kartik. We we are at time. I
just wanna say thank you. That was a
really nice look into some of those new
features. I think the remote agents are really
cool. The workflow improvements,
all of that. It's just super cool. And
adding on new chaos experiments that go beyond
where we already were just opens up so
many different potential avenues for breaking or breaking
Kubernetes, which to me is very exciting. I'm
I'm now trying to work out if I
can use Litmus
for some custard fun. So lots
lots for stuff for me to experiment with
there. Any last words before I let you
go for today?
Thank you for this opportunity once again. Really
enjoy being on this show and
talking
about the.
Looking
forward to breaking stuff on Kubernetes.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, check out principles of chaos. Check
out Litmus. Look forward to two point o.
Kartik, thank you again. Have a wonderful day,
and I'll see you all soon. Thanks.